Você sabia que a demência não é coisa só
de idoso? Pois olha só o que aconteceu
no Reino Unido. Um jovem de apenas 24
anos acabou de falecer após conviver com
demência afronto temporal. O André e
Arnan recebeu diagnóstico aos 22 anos e
é considerado o caso mais jovem já
registrado desse tipo de demência no
Reino Unido. Pois é, os exames de imagem
mostravam cérebro com aparência de
pessoa idosa um rapaz tão novo. Veja
bem, a demência frontemporal é diferente
do Alzheimer. Ela ataca principalmente a
parte da frente do cérebro, afeta
comportamento, personalidade e
linguagem. é uma doença que progrede
forma implacável e quando aparece tão
cedo assim, os cientistas ainda não
entendem completamente o porquê. A
família decidiu doar o cérebro dele pra
pesquisa. E isso é extremamente valioso,
porque casos assim são raríssimos e
podem revelar pistas importantes sobre
como essa doença se desenvolve. Esse
caso nos lembra que a ciência avança
também através de gestos de generosidade
em meio à dor.